oh my God this video shows an Alabama
cop tasing a man in the back even though
he was handcuffed disarmed in complying
with her orders according to 24-year-old
Micah Washington's girlfriend the
encounter started after police spotted
Washington and two others changing their
car's Tire on the side of the road
Washington was carrying marijuana and
had an illegal gun but he didn't pose
any obvious threat to Warrant the use of
force disturbingly it almost seems like
the officer enjoys hurting him oh yeah I
what you saying oh yeah oh my God this
is far from the first time police have
tased people unnecessarily La cops this
year killed a disoriented man after they
tased him six times in 2017 Arizona cops
tased a man 11 times during routine
traffic stop and last year Kansas police
hog tied and tased an autistic
12-year-old officers often Escape
accountability in situations like these
until they're held responsible expect
police abuse to keep happening